Detroit Lions football and the head
coach of the Detroit Lions entering his
second season as such joining us here on
the Rich Eisen show Matt Patricia how
are you coach I'm doing great thanks
super excited to be on the show we're in
the middle of training camp grinding it
away so it's pretty much like dog days
up here but that's what we love and just
you know real appreciative talk to you
I'm brewing right back right back at you
I do want to start real quick with with
the yesteryear part of it I don't know
how much you cross paths with Ty law but
you know is talking about ty earlier on
the program he's essentially the first
of the Belichick Craft and Brady era of
Patriots to get into the Hall of Fame he
is these basically breaking ground for
something that we're gonna see a lot of
guys getting in I wonder your two cents
on that subject coach yeah China are
actually very close I was there with Ty
and at the great you know blessing to
coach him and be on those great teams
with him and unbelievable competitor
great guy
obviously what I was still in New
England he was you know still out of the
area and you know just being able to
connect to him after the plane years and
he very much so you know one that all my
kids were doing and just involved with a
lot of the families and stuff he's just
he's an unbelievable person so so
excited so happy for him
so well deserved and and certainly you
know one of the best that I've been
around so just you know what a great
event but I agree I think you know ty is
breaking ground I think there is going
to be a lot of guys coming out of that
error that are going to be you know
walking through Canton and and we'll be
looking forward to all of them it's just
such you know special such a special
time for those guys and you know the
early part of the 2000s and you know
what a great group of guys yeah they and
I'm just wondering before we move on to
your team and the here and now you know
the the conversation is to who else
should get in and how sometimes we don't
hear their names mentioned very often
because of the do your job mantra and
how much credit coach Belichick in many
ways deservingly so does get for
these teams and their success and
there's no real individual standout
because of the team mentality who do you
think should stand out and get into the
Hall of Fame from those years coach you
got me right there so I'm gonna stay
with the team mentality that was bred so
well into us in those years and and you
know I think all of them deserve it's
just it was great great games certainly
you know coach Belichick is where it all
starts and unbelievable you know
opportunity to work with him and learn
from you know the greatest and just be
around him all the time but there's so
many good players from those teams you
know I hate to just ramble off some
names and forget someone because
honestly you know where does it stop
between you know the peoples accrue you
know Tedy Bruschi Mike Vrabel jr. say I
wouldn't McGinnis I mean I tell those
guys we had we had to pick some which
were um believe you know play with which
is unbelievable in the room at the time
to the all kinds of guys I mean all of
them I mean it's just just a great group
of players yeah there's also the World
Series of Poker champ in a way uh
Richard Seymour I mean Richard tie worn
on the other side and Vince obviously in
the middle and you know everybody had a
role on the team and everybody executed
as a high level you know Jarvis Green
would come in you know he'd get his
plays but you know for us I think it is
exactly we said it was all about team
and those guys you know that's that's
what they believed in and that's what
they played for and so it's hard to
separate anybody else Matt Patricia
Detroit Lions head coach here on the
Rich Eisen show and it was no surprise
to me and a lot of other observers that
you guys snapped up Trey flowers I'm
wondering if just making sure that you
know you brought in not only a talented
player but somebody clearly knows the
way things are done or the way you like
things done played into that signing
coach yeah you know you trade
unbelievable person he's a great kid
he's someone that and I know very well
as a young player and was able to watch
him progress as a professional and he's
approached every single day the way that
he attacks is his job and and continues
to get better as a player and then I
would say his work ethic and everything
that he is as a leader
from a standpoint of what he does every
single day to get ready to go is
something that has great value and I
think it's you know critically important
to be able to have those guys on your
team so that everybody else can get a
chance to see that too but I think for
us it's just a good great opportunity to
try to improve our team and build upon
the guys that we brought in you know in
a lot of positions and even you know
from the previous years and the players
that we have here and just try to put it
all together the best we can
yeah and then Mike Daniels being being
added what does he bring to your team
yeah another you know really strong
player and the defensive front guys very
intense player I have a lot of respect
for you know some of that as you look at
team you're trying to get ready to
prepare and you keep noticing someone
that's so disruptive and someone that is
just continually you know problem to
have to deal with doesn't take too long
before he starts playing Michael I need
to get that guy in my side of the ball
because I'm tired of having to deal with
him every single day so getting him in
the building getting his energy what he
has to do what you know what he brings
to the team and all of his
professionalism it's really been a
blessing from that standpoint it's just
he's great he's really great coach Matt
Patricia of the Detroit Lions here on
the Rich Eisen show what what about year
2 for you coach where year 1 was the
biggest adjustment from for you in year
1 do you think that you've got either a
better handle on or you know that you
need to address for your to would be
what yeah I think obviously you're
wanted it's just you know it's a little
bit of chaos especially you know coming
off the season I was the year before and
kind of being late into the mix of
getting here and trying to get things
set up and what does coaching staffs or
changes to the building or the you know
the players just getting to understand
you know who they all are and them
understanding who I am and trying to get
everything set up it's really a scramble
and I think you know you take the first
year you try to implement as much as you
can you try to assess as much as you can
and figure out what what do you like
what do not like what needs to change
and really try to put that into effect
in the second year so it's just been an
interesting second year from that
standpoint it was almost like after the
season ended you can kind of sit back
and say okay what
we really need to attack how do we
really need to make sure that everything
is operating at a high level and what do
we start with so it was great from that
standpoint certainly it's you know it's
going to be all about you know myself
first and foremost to get better and to
improve and there's a lot of areas that
I know that I got to get better at and
having a lot of great conversations with
the players through the course of the
spring and just kind of that open and
honest feedback back and forth about
things that we can all do better to help
us you know be more successful and
that's really what I value okay and
speaking of scrambling you got Kyler
Murray first up in a couple weeks coach
I mean the conversation all offseason
all play all non-playing season town
evaluation is whether this young man has
a game that can translate to the NFL
what what do you what are your thoughts
on that subject about whether Kyler
Murray at his height or bringing that
style of play to the NFL will be what is
your thoughts on the subject coach you
know I get to look at it first and
foremost maybe I could have had that
like game eight or something like that
after everybody else yeah you know see
what it's going to be but honestly with
him and clip and you know quick play for
me at New England's I know clip very
well great you know offensive mind
combined with extremely talented
quarterback you know that great skilled
players around them and it's going to be
very interesting challenge your first
game the first game in general in the
NFL is this huge unknown when you go
into the season because you don't look
at some preseason tape and you can kind
of try to guess and analyze what
everybody's going to do but until you
get into that first game you really
don't know it becomes a huge adjustment
game for you so it's a dangerous
situation for us to have to walk into we
know that going into it we're studying
what preparing we're trying to
understand you know every aspect of what
it could be but honestly until we get
into the game we're not going to know
and you know he's just a great player
and we're gonna have our hands full well
I mean it's not like you don't have some
mysteries of your own that you might be
able to present I mean is carry-on
johnson gonna be a bell cow back for you
this year do you think I mean I'm sure
we'll probably hold a few things back
and we'll see what happens there in that
first game myself you know
will unleash some things maybe and see
how they handle it too but I think carry
on in general is really you know growing
through the offseason I think the
addition of CJ Anderson has really been
you know great for us too and in the
running back room to to help him
TJ is an unbelievable professional
really works extremely hard the game you
love to the game he and I have had a lot
of battles through the course of the
year so I have a lot of respect for him
and you know we're just going to do with
best for us you know on the backfield
you know every single week you know I
think personally put the running back
situations or the course of the through
the entire league you know there's
probably only a couple backs that just
are in there every single down you know
the rest of it is going to be based on
situation or you know whatever's best
for those particular play calls and
we'll just do the best we can to kind of
make sure that we're featuring everybody
okay I'm just you know I'm trying to get
some fantasy football news out of you
coach that I should connect on my front
door well you know I'll be honest with
you I'm fishing still I'm fishing a
little bit I should have known a little
bit better I should just walk in through
the front door with those sorts of
things you know Matt Patricia here on
the Rich Eisen show do you have the
pencil in your behind your ear right now
like literally right now in my hand I
just took it out of my ear and you know
write a note down or something that you
were gonna give me some good information
so you actually use the pencil it is
actually used it's not just there as a
as a prop at all but it's there for use
pretty much it's used continually all
the time are you taking notes on my
interview style and then providing me
with any of your thoughts afterwards is
that is that what's happening right now
- okay well then before I let you go
then did you see the game last night at
all a little bit of it just kind of
asking we're pretty much working on
today's schedule and practice you're
coming up the next week but the reason
why I bring it up is Vic Fangio became
the first coach during our new era of
pass interference being reviewable
to throw a flag to try and challenge the
the call stood I'm wondering what you
think of all of this coach were you in
favor of pass interference being
reviewable yeah you know I think it's
great my pick to do that because I think
through the course of the preseason we
all have questions and we all have you
know situations that are come up that we
want to try to get as much information
now as we can before we get to the
season so I think we're going to see a
lot of that in the preseason you know
and I hope we do because I think the
more we can do that and get clarity the
more it's going to help us as we get to
the season to be able to make those
decisions and to be able to make those
choices so I think it's good for
everyone involved the coaches the
players the officials as many times as
we can kind of get that situation and
get it in the preseason I think it will
help us for the regular season so I
think you know that's great and as far
as you know would the ruled and all of
it I think from the coaching standpoint
I think we're letting everybody else
everybody just wants it right everybody
just wants to try to do the best they
can and certainly we all understand that
and hopefully we get it right so I think
they got it right last night would you
agree that they got it right and that it
stood as called it's not that they
confirmed it and they also didn't
overturn it do you think they got it
right last night I mean I think they you
know from an operation standpoint I
think they were trying to do exactly
what we talked about you know so again I
think it'll be interesting to see how it
goes to the course of the large body of
examples coach appreciate the time man
and and and always appreciate your your
generosity and supporting my run not
just with your words but with with your
your wallet and you have been very very
supportive and I think people should
know that so that's why I want to thank
you publicly appreciate it that's really
very kind of you you know I think the
world of you and all the work that you
do and you know it's just we had an
opportunity you and I had an opportunity
to catch up at the Super Bowl and you
know just you telling the stories really
hit home with me and you know we all got
to do more and you know you're leading
the charge so we got to follow suit and
just you know we got to get in line
anything I can do you know never
hesitate to ask
I appreciate that coach thanks so much
good luck with the Honolulu blue and
let's catch up during the during the
season I can't wait I can't wait
preciate you having me out take care you
got that's Matt Patricia head coach of
the Detroit Lions for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app